from calorie counterpotion says we want
to find out all the differences between
Taco Bell in India and the US this is
food Wars
here India our typical tacos come in
orders of one two in a two taco meal
with fries and a drink three Taco Trio
combo which comes with nachos and a
drink or on weekends they have a special
offer where you can get eight tacos in
their weekend taco party breakfast
eight weekend party pack taco
have a party with your friends only
there are eight of them and they all are
okay with having this one taco in the
U.S our standard Taco Bell tacos come in
orders of one three with a drink and the
12 Taco Box 12 tacos one box item here
in India a classic burrito is six and a
half centimeters or six and a half
inches our U.S burrito is five inches
across in terms of good it's the first
time I've measured the growth of
anything promise seven inches also about
five inches and that's what matters most
okay now to measure the weight of our
classic burrito damn this is a big boy
291 grams
185 grams our classic quesadilla is just
shy of 11 inches 10 inches and as for
weight
and it weighs 174 grams 202 grams add an
Indian Taco Bell the largest item we
have on our menu is the aforementioned
weekend eight taco party picnic pop in
water is this thing eight Taco weekend
party pack and it's always a party
so the vegetarian version is 499 rupees
and the non-rated version is 599 rupees
in the US our biggest menu item is a
supreme variety taco party pack it is
12. supreme tacos and it runs 21.99 or
1751.65 Indian rupee
here's everything you'll find at a Taco
Bell in India that you will not find in
the US and here is everything at a U.S
Taco Bell you can't find in India let's
Taco about it here in India all of the
tacos have a vegetarian option it's
because even though India is a primarily
non-vegetarian country we have a huge
population of vegetarians or people who
have different preferences of what kind
of meat they like to eat and so it's
great for most of these fast food chains
to have a lot of veg options all of them
have the option of either pinto beans
fajita veggies or Mexican paneer and
they're also in increasing order of
spice the cheesy double decker Taco
honestly I actually really like this
Taco I know it's sacred for some people
to eat a softer and hard shell taco
together but when you parcel this stuff
and get it delivered to you both the
tacos become soft shell
all right the next taco I'm gonna eat is
a crunchy taco plain and simple it's got
pinto beans in it it's unfair to like
this on a crunchy taco after you've
ordered it from a restaurant that's far
away because look at this it's become
soggy already so I'm gonna be gentle on
my criticism of this but you use soft
shell tacos are getting it huh
let's do some decent crunch to it here
in India pinto beans are what we call
rajma and they're a staple in lava rajma
so it's a perfect match to put them in a
taco next up another crunchy taco this
one is the Mexican paneer now paneer if
you're unaware is cottage cheese we make
it all over here in India we basically
take curdle milk add some sort of fruit
or vegetable acid to it like lemon juice
and you get cottage cheese which is
paneer I'm curious to know what makes
this Mexican
paneer is one of the most popular things
you'll find in India at any restaurant
this paneer tastes chalky like most
processed bunny that you'd store in a
freezer wood if you prefer your paneer
chunky you might enjoy this not so much
now on to the soft shell tacos uh this
one is Mexican paneer the same thing I
just had
this Mexican paneer is a little bit more
spicy my favorite thing about tacos is
that not every bite is uniform so you
get a lot of different textures and
flavors in each bite you take and I
guess that's proving its point over here
okay so the next one we're gonna try is
a soft taco with fajita veggies inside
I'm opting out of the fajita veggies as
a filling in general and finally we have
our last veggie option which is a veggie
Fiesta which has tater tots
win that's a win if I was gonna talk
about I had to order a veggie Taco for
some reason my option would be a crunchy
pinto bean taco and now for our
non-vegetarian tacos please note that
all of the meat in our tacos is chicken
and not beef this is because we have a
huge percentage of Hindus here in India
and they do not eat beef this makes all
of our non-veg tacos exclusives because
yes in the U.S you can substitute your
beef for chicken but it's not on the
official menu all right it's a
modification which means these are more
exclusives to India okay so you have two
options of filling either Mexican
chicken or grilled chicken we're
starting off with a grilled chicken
crunchy taco which has severely
disintegrated not bad this is also kind
of the test of Taco Bell's uh structural
Integrity pretty good
[Music]
that's a win for me what else do you
want Taco Bell this Taco though has seen
better times
it kind of reminds me of like a rajma
chawl when you're chewing on naraz
myself that's how soft the chicken is
there are a lot of comparisons you can
make with Mexican and Indian food we
have something exactly like this in
India it's called chapati and it's made
out of wheat the tortillas in Mexico are
typically made with corn the one in Taco
Bell is made out of maida which is
all-purpose flour I can't speak for
Mexican Cuisine but there's definitely a
lot of Indian flavors in this
this is actually a soft grilled chicken
taco and I can wholeheartedly say worst
of the bunch don't get this one a cheese
double decker Taco with grilled chicken
again come on man I wanted the Mexican
one but the hard shell taco is
disintegrating into a soft shell tacos
there's nothing special Chicken Fiesta
taco oh my God I didn't expect that at
all
if I've been chewing for so long I'm so
tired oh damn the aftertaste of this is
really good this is not a nice spice to
it now we have a very special Taco as
you can see this one is still wrapped
because I've never seen this in my life
it's called a naked chicken taco pause
for a moment what do you think that
means oh my God ladies and gentlemen
the naked chicken taco
[Music]
genuinely feels like I just undressed
food so there's no chicken filling
inside it because the chicken is the
Taco that's right that's how far we've
come as the human race we have taken
this bird and turn it into a freaking
pancake and folded it over cheese your
scientists were too busy trying to
figure out whether they could do it they
didn't stop to think whether they should
do it
I think that might be one of the worst
things I've had on this show oh God oh
God
I'm gonna be honest it actually looks
pretty good to me that reminds me of the
KFC double down which I did actually
enjoy I try it starting off soft taco
and soft taco supreme which is beef
flimsiest thing in the world
this stuff is all this stuff is sweating
already
so I don't know how many vegetarians are
watching now but look at what you're
missing I think I just created a few
vegetarians I mean I like how they taste
but I mean Taco Bell's got so much fun
stuff on the menu what are you doing in
regular tacos like get out of here it's
crunchy taco which we saw earlier
fantastic even a little more stuff in it
the cream Taco it really loaded up with
the veggies India India India look at me
this is my favorite thing in the Taco
Bell menu I sing its phrases at every
Taco Bell food Wars it is the nacho
cheese Doritos Locos Tacos some genius
somewhere connected Taco Bell and
Doritos to make a hard shell taco that
is in fact a Doritos ciao
mmm comes in standard and of course
Supreme
because I've been looking forward to
this all day it's burrito time baby I've
gotten a Mexican paneer version here as
well as a pinto beans version I think
I'll go with the pinto beans one by the
way this tray is all of the vegetarian
burritos and this is the non vegetarian
tray happy baby India has a lot of roll
culture we have Kati rules we have
kolkataros we also have shawarmas which
we are a huge fan of
most Indians this basically will feel
like you took rajma rice and you shoved
it inside a maida roti I think I'd go
with the taco over this next up we have
tikka masala but I found this out
recently it was actually invented by the
British so clearly inspired by India but
invented by them another thing that the
British took from us that we haven't
been paid back for
we have a flavor here it's called achary
and it's basically like a pickle this is
more achary than chicken tikka masala
also I would be lying if I didn't admit
that Taco Bell it's all it's already
doing its thing to my digestive system
Taco Bell is notorious for making you go
to the bathroom zoom in to my stomach
right now and just listen to this the
noises and let's get a translation
oh my God and now for Sriracha wedge
burrito is now running the risk of
offending three different cultures I
don't normally eat a burrito by ripping
it in half actually that sounds awesome
we should do that more often like a
double-handed don't clip that
you can skip it we have the seven layer
burrito
this one tastes like all of these put
together and we have one last veg wrap
ah guys I can't do this it's the same
thing this is tater tots that same
feeling I bow down and defeat Taco Bell
you have vanquished me moving on to the
non vegetarian burritos and we're hoping
some of these are a little more distinct
from the others all right we have a
classic Mexican chicken burrito
oh so bad this is damn bad let's just
say I'm glad you didn't call yourself
burrito bowl next up tikka masala but
now in non-witch
[Music]
this is actually quite good this one
doesn't taste as dry as the other ones
I've had and of course we have the seven
layer non-vegetarian burrito instead of
paneer we have grilled chicken let's
just do the slab test again
you could really hurt somebody with this
seven layer one okay we have one last
burrito which is why what is this this
is not why have you done this this
burrito looks like the the love child of
all other burritos over here these
burritos are definitely related and this
is the product of incest
honestly out of all of these I'd prefer
to finish this one because it's just
smaller the pain will end faster
burritos might not be visually the most
exciting part of the video but please
don't leave maybe just open some clips
of Family Guy next to it so you can
watch that and this like you're on Tick
Tock the double steak grilled cheese
burrito and the spicy double steak
grilled cheese burrito and right it's
grilled cheese because they like Grill
it shut which is genius idea yeah look
at that it has jalapenos on it oh that's
fantastic that's a really great idea
oh yeah just rules a beefy quesarito
when these things cool off though this
is a lot of cheese in there oh and it
has a rice in it little burritos have
rice I don't know I'm so surprised by
the way rice on a burrito same thing but
with black beans I mean it's already
kind of kind of like dripping out there
already grilled number one beans and
cheese in there you see that and the red
is uh those like chips they put those
crispy chips in there five layer burrito
it used to be seven layer took out two
layers and added a beefy one for some
weird reason I assure you there's five
layers and beef inside I'm not doing
that I'm not some weird fetish that on
the internet that I'm not aware of
slapping faces with burritos burrito
supreme look it's so much different from
the last thing we were just looking at
but like that one's just like
CK chipotle chicken
yeah Chipotle Nails legit an extra one
if anyone wants it go ahead and comment
below and I'll mail it to you beefy
melts beef and melted cheese I can't
believe it together at last
I mean it tastes like all the other ones
I feel like we could pair this menu down
a little bit last and not least cheesy
bean and rice now for India's
Specialties I am excited for the
diversity that's all I'll say very
representative of our country let's
start off with the chalupa The Humble
chalupa
it's nice if you guys are at home
wondering what the difference between a
normal taco and a chalupa is you should
Google it what is this I mean education
show I'm sure to eat man for my Indian
present it's kind of the difference
between a chapati and like a batura they
actually fry it a little bit
but that was a very horrible place to
bite because I only got chicken I have
soft spot for the chalupa and it gets my
approval we have the weight star wrap
voila so inventive let's take a burrito
but make it flat oh wow don't make me
eat this Insider please
oh
I'm coming from a country where we're
used to eating something like this a
chapati with a sabzi on the side which
is like a curry which has vegetables and
fresh paneer and maybe some chicken so
to eat something like this just feels
not even supper it just feels wrong I'm
actually curious to know if any Mexicans
watching this video okay let me know in
the comments whether you feel like Taco
Bell has done Justice to representing
your cuisine in any way next up we have
a Kickstart count of Applause I'm just
gonna keep this UFO of man's worst
accomplishment over here quesadilla
fajita veg very thin I'm curious to know
how they fit a lot of fajita veggies
into it
they haven't how do people do this my
God I just realized Joe is insane how
have you eaten so much Taco Bell Joe
yeah I'm insane I lost my mind somewhere
during the Japan season oh well and it's
strange because I'm still an intern
we're doing high schools now yeah it
looks really good
um if it was abstract art in a museum
about 20 meters away from your eyeballs
but when you come close and then you're
faced with the proposition of eating it
ah
I can feel my body rejecting this
otherwise it's fine I mean it's it's
just very average this is a normal rice
bowl
we have the same thing another Rice Bowl
but this time it's got some grilled
chicken in there
that was really good this feels like the
safest bet ah I don't know when anything
is still so let's go through together
the first thing this is uh either a
black bean chalupa or a dirty diaper I
can't tell because it's thick and
wrinkly and just dripping with black goo
don't want that oh it's this uh yeah I
mean every time these Doritos shells
shop I'm just happy Dorito Cheesy
Gordita Crunch nacho cheese they put
every word in that
oh it's that thing but not nachos I mean
once you have the Dorito shell version
like to go back is like no way no way
I've touched the sky I couldn't stay on
the ground no longer and then we have
two Crunchwrap Supreme options black
bean Crunchwrap Supreme and then the
regular Crunchwrap Supreme is of course
filled with beef okay it's time now for
India's sides menu starting off with
Mexican corn salad
you don't need to add so much sauce to
it I feel like this could have been a
lot simpler and people would appreciate
it more next up we have loaded fries and
loaded uh nachos so typically Taco Bell
does not serve loaded nachos and loaded
fries here in India but we found a
restaurant that was kind enough to send
it to us anyways I will say this is
probably my favorite thing about Taco
Bell in India the loaded nachos are
banging when you get them at the
restaurant
[Music]
like wet cardboard and now we have two
bath bags just kidding chicken nachos
they had chicken tacos and now there are
chicken nachos and our second doggy bag
has whoa that was alarming because what
I saw was this I did not expect this to
come out of that bag crispy chicken
strips sides baby we got them cheesy
Fiesta potatoes
there's better things to be had on the
menu if I do like those black beans
black beans and rice and you can get a
guacamole side now here are some items
that are available both in India and the
us but are still very different for
example this is India's quesadilla
grilled cheese quesadilla but as you can
see it's filled with a lot of fajita
veggies it's got like this special
creamy sauce and it's topped with a lot
of jalapenos whereas in the U.S it comes
with just cheese how boring is that
correct and this is what it looks like
incredibly boring another big difference
is here in India are nachos are all
season so they already have like a
masala or some sort of spice to them our
nacho chips in the US are just regular
tortilla chips with nacho cheese
here in India in our veg options we use
we use whereas in the US our Bean of
choice is the black bean exclusive U.S
sauces hey you know what that means
it's now time for India's exclusive
sauces we have quite the wide range we
have pool Ranch because there's a lot of
spice in a lot of these burritos and
tacos I imagine if you're somebody who
can't tolerate spice definitely get a
side of this then there is spicy salsa I
tasted it it's really nice it's got a
lot more spiced it but also the flavor
of imli which is tamarind we use it in a
lot of our dishes especially South
Indian dishes then there's a chocolate
sauce which I imagine is for churros or
some sort of dippable dessert but if you
want to dip your quesadilla into this
I'm not gonna judge next up we have lava
sauce which doesn't really look as much
like lava but it definitely has a kick
to it chicken tikka masala sauce which
looks more like lava down in the end
here we got reduced fat sour cream who
doesn't like chips and sour cream right
could use some fat then moving on we
have a chipotle sauce Ole sauce is very
good
avocado ranch
I love it more of that please they have
a spicy ranch how spicy could it be not
very and finally the red sauce okay it
is finally dessert time I have eaten a
lot of savory food and I'm excited for
the desserts good old churros I am a big
fan of churros they send you one
chocolatey dip
I feel like you can't really go wrong
with Churros if you want to call
yourself a restaurant and next is
something I have never seen before
cinnamon twisties
I could see myself you know 3am in the
night sad vulnerable eating a whole
packet of these so that means it's a
good dessert Taco Bell used to sell
quesadillas filled with chocolate and
they were called choco Diaz but I guess
they've stopped that now Taco Bell is
against puns the only U.S exclusive
dessert we have are these the Cinnabon
Delights Cinnabons I'm pretty sure this
is filled with some sort of like cream
cheese right
I share this cream cheese in this or
whatever they're frosting someone's got
to eat that definitely can't go to waste
eat it now
right they're fantastic all right it's
time for India's exclusive drinks what
could we do without them nothing out of
choke to death on all that burrito maida
wrap first up uh the soft drinks that we
have we sell 7Up and Miranda over here
but actually in Bangalore I've seen a
lot more variety of drinks so I think it
varies from store to store next up Taco
Bell sells juices this one was a mixed
fruit juice but I drank it all and I can
tell you it was pretty good they also
sell a cranberry and apple juice but the
stores that we asked in Mumbai did not
have those available and finally they
sell milkshakes this is mango this is
chocolate cookie crumble the true test
of a milkshake is to test the fruit one
and see if it's still fresh
hey that's pretty good mango milkshake
U.S exclusive drinks there's literally a
million yes really of soft drinks you
can get a Taco Bell you can't get in
India so I just went and got a Diet
Pepsi and of course
Baja Blast after like doing this what
three four times at this point I'm
actually starting to like Baja Blast do
you think I should get a whole bunch of
soft drinks at the US Taco Bell all of
these
I wasn't getting 20 drinks you know so
get yourself a bottle OJ Tropicana also
something you can get are things called
freezes which at one point were frozen
slushy or slurpy like drinks you can get
of course a Mountain Dew and also get
yourself Wild Cherry fruits
that's cough syrup
also you can get coffee both iced and
hot
iced coffee
oh no wait that's soda what is this
ignore that over there
gave us two of these iced coffee that's
flavored like the Cinnabon the lights
are you kidding me I can just feel my
life expectancy just getting closer and
closer just like sip
he ain't seen his 80s
but it's worth that's delicious you can
also get those coffees Hot Taco Bell
breakfast baby
I think this is just about everything
once again I can't tell what anything is
it's all just a sea of beige let's find
out together this one just says bacon
thank you for that burrito with bacon
I'm like the Riddler over here just like
Yay figured out question mark question
mark I mean it's a bit unnatural how
yellow that is it's really bright it's a
bit concerning this one's gonna be the
one with steak I assume
who's hungry
stick's a little weird maybe I don't get
the steak one specifically I'll just see
this this kind of station how bad this
food is sweating Breakfast Crunchwrap
Supreme oh there's sausage inside of
this what comes inside like the magic
ticket now I get to work at Taco Bell or
something their sausage is good though
get yourself a hash brown They also have
breakfast salsa with the Taco Bell I
went to did not have any
let's talk about nutrition everybody's
favorite topic that's why you come to
food Wars because you love fast food but
mainly you love nutrition in India a
typical soft shell Mexican chicken taco
will be 185 calories in the US our
standard chicken soft taco is 160
calories so we have fewer calories fat
carbs and sodium but more protein next
up is a chicken quesadilla ours has
268.5 calories and ours is 510 calories
now please note the sodium level on our
quesadilla it's over half the daily
recommended amount that's a salty
quesadilla in India a vegetar app is
239.9 calories closest way after that is
our black bean Crunchwrap Supreme again
double the calorie count get a load of
that sodium
are you looking for the most calorific
item in
here then the cinnamon twist each of
these packets will cost you 480.9
calories here in the US if you're having
a hard time finding calories at the Taco
Bell check out this the double beef
grilled cheese burrito
so Taco Bell in India does not disclose
any other ingredients but I thought it
would be interesting to talk about two
of the ingredients that we have here
that are unique to India number one is
paneer so the problem with the Mexican
paneer that was served to me in this
batch of Taco Bell is that it tasted
like the process paneer you get at
stores it tasted like something that had
been stored in a fridge also because
paneer is so popular here in India every
single fast food restaurant has paneer
options you know when you know how well
it can be done I didn't like the paneer
that much in the burritos and tacos I
had today the next ingredient I want to
talk about is Tikka Masala I thought it
was okay it had a lot of flavor it was
quite spicy but the thing that makes
tikka masala so exciting is that it's
always made from fresh tomatoes and so
you can sort of tell there's a
difference when it's in the sauce form
however I will say it's always a valiant
effort to see these fast food companies
and people who come here from abroad in
general adapt to the Indian palette and
try to make Cuisine that matches ours in
the US we do disclose our ingredients
and here's a few you should be wary of
first is brominated vegetable oil AKA
BVO BVO is an emulsifier found in Citrus
flavored sodas that specifically use
citrus oils and is considered a health
risk when ingested in large amounts in
one case a man who drank two to four
liters of BVO soda per day developed
bromism and experienced symptoms such as
memory loss and extreme muscle fatigue
it can be found in the ingredients of
three of the Cantina menu freezes the
beach Berry freeze the ginger mule
freeze and the party punch freeze the
last one the party punch freeze also
contains yellow number five AKA tired
which is subject to restriction outside
the U.S in places like the EU and India
as it quote may have a diverse effect on
activity and attention in children and
you can find it in several Taco Bell
menu items specifically the Doritos
Locos Taco nacho cheese shells oh no I
had like three of those today and Baja
Blast I just want to starting to like it
I just want to shout out to Jewel and
say I understand what drama you must be
going through after doing so many Taco
Bell episodes you know brave brave man
you